There is a ceasefire now between Iran
and United States. But most analysts
expect that this war will resume
in a week, two weeks, a month. But it
will it will resume because it is
impossible for the United States and
Iran to come to a mutually beneficial
and satisfying
um arrangement. So today I want to look
at how this war will evolve. And my
argument to you today is that this US
Iran war, it's really the first war of
the 21st century.
Um, and so I want to explain to you how
warfare has evolved these past few
hundred years. So the simplest way to
fight a war is you would destroy a
state's capacity to fight by killing as
many soldiers as possible, right? You
would arrange to fight the enemy on a
battlefield. Whoever wins this uh battle
would win the war and that was how
traditionally wars wars were fought for
hundreds and hundreds of years. But in
20th century something happened which is
that the state and nation state they
have the capacity to have a lot of
people millions of people. And so the
state could always replenish its forces
on the battlefield. And so now what you
had to do was you had to destroy the
state's capacity
to produce to manufacture.
Okay? And this is really so the point is
to kill as many civilians as possible
before you wanted to kill as many
soldiers as possible. But in the 20th
century war, mainly World War II, you're
trying to kill as many civilians as
possible. But in the 21st century, it's
different because we have nuclear
weapons now and there are too many
people. So it is impossible for you to
kill everyone and if you use nuclear
weapons then others will use nuclear
will use nuclear weapons on you. Okay.
So now in the 21st century our goal is
to use the population against the state
to turn the civilians against the
government by sowing as much discord and
descent as possible within society and
you do that through economic sabotage
economic strangulation. Okay. Okay. So
that's the argument I will make to you
um today. The first thing I want to look
at is why is it that we have 8 billion
people?
8 billion people are living on this
planet. And for most of us we think this
is a tremendous achievement. But if you
think about it, it's not that nice
because there aren't that many resources
to share. There's not that much that
much space. In fact, if it were not for
fertilizers, we would only be able to
support 1 to two billion people. So, how
do we get to a stage where 8 billion
people in this world and most of us are
are not very happy with the state
affairs? Okay. And scientists will tell
you it's because of the revolution. It's
because of this revolution in technology
and understanding that's allowed us to
progress. That's not true. Okay? The
real reason is because of the nation
state
and the nation state it is a revolution
in politics that came to us because of
the French revolution. All right. So um
the main architect of the French
revolution his name is Jeanjac Rouso. He
was he was not French. He was he was
actually um Swiss.
But he's important because he developed
a theory that underpinned the French
French Revolution called social contract
theory.
Before we didn't really think about what
the individual's relationship with the
state was. Basically, you were born into
community and you just did what
tradition and custom and family asked
you to do. But Jeanja Rouso was the
first to say no, we are born free
because God gave us freedom. So why do
we choose to surrender our freedom in
order to join a community? Okay. And so
his theory is that we join society to
become more free.
So
by ourselves
um
um we together
okay all of us together we create
something called a common will and think
of this as democracy.
Democracy is basically idea idea that to
make a decision we just vote and then
whatever comes whichever is the majority
wins. So for example, we might debate
whether we go to McDonald's or Pizza
Hut. Okay, there's three of us. If two
of you say let's go to Pizza Hut, we go
to Pizza Hut because that's democracy
for Jean Rouso. This is not a good
system because we should strive to be
higher than we are. We should strive for
total freedom and that's the idea of the
general will. Okay, the common will is
who we are. The general will is who we
could be if we came together as a
people. Okay. And the best way to
understand the general will is through
Kant's theory of the categorical
imperative.
Okay, which is for him the highest moral
law.
So as human beings, what makes us truly
human? What allows us to achieve our
ideal state are three principles. Okay.
The first principle is a principle of
universality.
So imagine that all your actions
will be reflected throughout the
universe. So if you smile, everyone
smiles at once. If you get angry,
everyone gets angry at once. And you ask
yourself, what sort of society do I do I
want to live in? Do I want to live in a
society where everyone is smiling or
angry? Right? And then that's the way
you should behave. Yeah, the law of
universality. Second is the idea of free
will.
No one can compel you to smile. You must
smile out of your own free choice.
Even though smiling makes you feel
happy, if I make you smile, that goes
against
um the
good of humanity. Okay. The third is the
idea of human as an ends.
Okay. So I can never sacrifice another
human being in order to achieve a better
society because we are the ultimate end.
Okay. So these these together um the
categorical imperative is what gives us
the theory of the general will. So
even though we all vote to eat ice
cream, we shouldn't eat ice cream
because that's not how we we achieve
enlightenment. That's not how we achieve
the ideal state, right? Right? We should
think about Kant's category imperative.
Now what happens is this from the
general will this is a sovereign. Okay.
This is the highest law. This is God
basically. And from the sovereign we
achieve the state, the government.
And the state makes us into citizens.
And then we have laws,
culture,
education.
Okay. So for John Rouso, this is the
social contract. This is the ideal
state. The French revolution started
because there were many intellectuals,
revolutionaries who wanted to achieve
the social contract.
But as you can as you can appreciate
there were many who disagreed with this
theory especially monarchs right because
the idea here is that the general will
the people are the sovereign but in in a
monarchy the monarch is what's
sovereign.
So the sovereign must so it's a debate
over who's sovereign and so at this time
in history most nations most countries
in Europe were monarchies. So they saw
the French Revolution as a direct threat
um to them and that's why they invaded
France
many many times. But then something
really weird happened. these
professional armies who go into France
and they're fighting against these
citizens. Okay, people with no military
experience who are not professional
soldiers was happening was that they
were losing to the citizen armies.
And the question is why was this
happening?
And the reason why is that
this theory
is so powerful that makes people willing
to fight to die for this. Okay?
Right? So what was happening during the
French Revolution, these wars, was that
you had the monarchies
and these were professional armies.
And so these were basically mercenaries.
And the thing about mercenaries is they
didn't want to die, right? They're
collecting a paycheck. Their point is to
intimidate. The point is to scare. It's
not to die. But then you have the French
Revolution
and they were citizens
and they were willing to fight and die.
Okay? And that's why France became the
most powerful nation in Europe at this
time because they could call on their
citizens to fight and to die and it was
almost unlimited amount of soldiers.
Whereas the um other countries like
Prussia, Russia, Austria
um they had professional soldiers who
were afraid to die. They all all they
wanted was their paycheck. So over time
the French were overwhelming the um
um Europeans and this created the French
Empire. All right. But once these these
places were conquered, they had they
developed their own theory as to how to
defeat the French and they recognized
that we also need a theory of
nationalism. We also need a theory of
the nation state. But they didn't like
the social contract theory. Okay. So
they came up with a new theory um based
on nation
which was basically language,
culture and race. And so these are this
this becomes Germany.
Okay. Or what we call iron
and blood.
So now you have these theories of
nationalism come out into Europe and now
they're invincible because they can call
on their citizens to fight and to die.
This is why Europe became the most
powerful region of the world starting in
the 19th century. Okay. But of course,
the problem with nationalism, the
problem with populations that want to d
fight and die is that they keep on
fighting wars.
But is that a real and so what happens
is that to solve this problem, all these
nations focus on trying to grow the
population as fast as possible, as much
as possible. This and this is what led
to this massive population growth.
But with more population, what was
happening was that these wars were
becoming deadlier and dead deadlier,
culminating, of course, in World War II.
And by World War II, Europe had
exhausted itself. Too many people had
died. Their civilization was destroyed.
And so this allowed America to come into
power. Okay, America.
And America
had a different theory of the nation
state. So the French theory was the
social contract. The Germans, their
theory is iron and blood, okay? Race.
The Americans had a different theory
because America was a multicultural
nation of immigrants who are trying to
colonize the um Western Hemisphere,
North America, right? So for them their
theory is to create a game. The nation
state becomes a game.
The Constitution
and government are the game masters.
And what they will allow is for anyone
to come to America
and get rich as long as they work hard.
And this will create the greatest nation
in the world. Okay? So this becomes a
game where anyone can play. In fact, the
more players that you have,
the wealthy America becomes, right?
And then after World War II, what
happened was that America spread this
game throughout the world as much as as
as much as they could, right, to Europe
and to Japan. But there are still
communist countries like China and
Soviet Union which did not want to
participate in this game. They had their
own game. And so what happened was that
after the collapse of the Soviet Union,
this game conquered the world, right?
You had globalization.
Okay. The problem is this. Once this
game keeps on going, eventually what
happens is that only a few players
achieve all the wealth, right? you have
massive inequality and everyone else
become falls into debt. Okay? And that's
the world that we live in today. America
created this game. It was very
successful in creating tremendous wealth
and they're trying to have as many
players as possible. That's why you you
have the population boom.
But now only a few people have all the
wealth and everyone else is in debt. In
other words,
these people are useless and therefore
we need to reset the game.
And the way to reset the game, of
course, is to destroy the game in the
first place. Therefore, have World War
II, burn everything down, and start the
game over again. Okay? And that's why we
are in the situation we are in today.
Okay? So now what and so now what what
what I'm going to do is go over some of
the major ideas that allowed for
this system to come into being. Okay. So
first I want to look look at the social
contract by Jeanjac Rouso. So um Ivory
could you do me a favor and and read the
first passage?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So um let me provide some context.
This is from his book called the social
contract and John Rouso is arguing that
slavery and before it was understood
that slavery is is a good system because
the master is nice to the slave. As long
as the master is nice to the slave the
slave should be happy and Jean Rouso
says no that cannot be true. In no under
no circumstance can a slave ever be
happy. Okay. And he explains why. So can
you read please? To renounce your
liberty is to renounce your status as a
man, your rights as a human being, and
even your duties as a human being. There
can be any way of compensating someone
who gives up everything. Such a
renunciation is incompatible with a
man's nature. To remove all freedom from
his will is to remove all morality from
his actions. Finally, an agreement to
have absolute authority on one side and
unlimited obedience on the other. What
an empty and contra contradictory
agreement that would have to be. Isn't
it clear that if we are entitled to take
anything and everything from a person,
we can't be under any obligation to him?
And isn't that fact alone the fact that
there is no equivalent, nothing to be
exchanged between the two sides enough
to nullify the agreement? What right can
my slave have against me? Everything
that he has is mine, his right is mine,
and it doesn't make sense to speak my
right against myself. Okay. So the
argument is this. Our freedom is given
to us by God. Our freedom is what
connects us to God. So our our freedom
cannot be surrendered. If we surrender
our freedom, if someone takes our
freedom away from us, that is
surrendering our humanity. That is
bringing our connection to God.
Therefore, it is better to die than be a
slave. And that was their thinking
during the French Revolution. Right? You
have all these citizens. They have
absolutely no experience with firearms.
But they were running into cannon fire
against professional soldiers because
they were like give me liberty or give
me death because without my liberty I am
nothing. Okay, so this is a really
important concept. Um and then uh you
can read this below.
>> I'm continually astonished that such a
simple sign of good government isn't
recognized or perhaps men do recognize
it but aren't honest enough to say so.
What is the purpose of any political
association?
The preservation and prosperity of its
members. And what is a shest sign of
their preservation and prosperity? Their
number and their population growth.
That's the sign you're looking for.
Other things being equal, the
unquestionably best government is the
one under which the population increases
most without external help from
naturalizing foreigners or establishing
colonies. The government under which the
population shrinks is the worst. Over to
you calculators. Count, measure,
compare.
>> Okay, this really important idea. Okay,
so the first is um liberty is the most
important value
and the second idea is a good
government, a good society should focus
on population growth, on having as many
people as possible because that's the
best sign that you're you're thriving as
a society. Okay. So because of these con
two two ideas, okay, population growth
and then um liberty,
the French will become the greatest
empire in Europe at this time. So this
is France in in the uh uh dark green and
they will colonize and conquer
everything in the green. You can see how
vast it is. Right? So this shows you the
power of the nation state based on two
ideas. The first idea is liberty is all
that matters. Second idea is grow the
population as fast as possible.
Okay.
Um so of course what happens as I
mentioned is that the Germans who are
being conquered by the French they get
upset and their intellectuals come up a
new theory of nationalism. This is uh
Johan Fete who is the considered the
father of German naturalism. His
argument is that it is language
that binds us as humans. Okay. So for
Rouso it's liberty that we should strive
for. It's liberty that gives us value as
human beings. But for Johan it's no it's
language. It's language that binds us to
the past. It's language that binds us
together.
It's language that's worth fighting for.
It's race, nation, blood. Okay? And this
becomes the philosophy of the German
state. At this time in history, Germany
was divided into many hundreds of
different kingdoms. It is Bismar,
Ottoman Bismar of Prussia will unify the
German people into one Germany. Okay?
Often called the second Reich.
And so um can c can you read uh Ivory
this this is a speech or his famous iron
and blood speech. Okay.
>> The position of pressure in Germany will
not be determined by its liberalism but
by its power. Prussia must concentrate
its strength and hold it for the
favorable moment which has already come
and gone several times. Since the
treaties of Vienna, our frontiers have
been illdesigned for a healthy body
politic. Not through speeches and
majority decisions will the great
questions of the day be decided. That
was the great mistake of 1848 and 1849,
but by iron and blood.
>> Okay. All right. So they here is that
listen, we're a German nation. Okay. And
as a nation state, as a people, we must
protect our freedom by going to war.
Okay? It's only by through war that we
can survive and thrive as a people. But
how do you fight wars? Well, you fight
wars and it's really important by making
sure your population is taken care of.
Okay. So, c can can you read um Ivory?
>> The real grievance of the worker is the
insecurity of his existence. He is not
sure that he will always have work. He's
not sure that if he will always be
healthy. And he foresees that he will
one day be old and unfit to work. If he
falls into poverty, if even if only
through a prolonged illness, he is then
completely helpless, left to his own
devices, and society does not currently
recognize any real obligation toward him
beyond their usual help for the poor,
even if he has been working all the time
ever so faithfully and diligently. The
usual help for the poor, however, leaves
a lot to be desired, especially in large
cities where it is very much worse than
in the country. Right. So, Bismar will
turn Germany into the most powerful
nation in the world by recognizing that
it's not just soldiers who contribute to
the war effort. It's also your people as
well. It's your people who make the
machines of war, the the uh machine
guns, the uh artillery,
the ammunitions. And therefore, you have
to make sure they are healthy. You don't
want to send six soldiers to a
battlefield, right? you well you don't
want sick sick workers as well. That's
why he passed a lot of progressive
worker reforms including health
insurance, accidental insurance, old age
pension, workers protection, children
protection. Okay. It is because he
recognizes that a nation state is first
and foremost about making warriors
and if you want to win you you have you
have to make sure you have as many
people as possible and everyone is
contribute to the war effort. make and
to do that you need to make sure that
everyone is taken care of including your
soldiers including your workers.
Okay. And it was Mussolini who
basically understood that the real
purpose of a nation state is to fight
wars. In fact, it is wars that give
people meaning in their lives. If you
have a war, if you create a nation state
around war, you create a mythology
around the beauty of war, then people
will happily fight and die. Okay. C can
you read a speech?
>> We have created our myth. The myth is a
faith, a passion. It is not necessary
for it to be a reality. It is a reality
in the sense that is it is a stimulus,
is hope, is faith, is courage. Our myth
is the nation. Our myth is the greatness
of the nation. And to this myth, this
greatness which we want to translate
into a total reality, we subordinate
everything else.
>> Okay. So this is the highlight or the
peak of the um nation state. And so
during World War II,
they had to fight a war to destroy the
entire society because the soldiers were
not a mercenary army like they were in
the past before. The soldiers were
coming from the population themselves.
So in World War II, the Allies won not
because they were democratic or morally
superior or had better strategy. It was
because they they could destroy the
productive capacity of their enemies but
their enemies could not destroy the
productive capacity of their nation
states. Does that make sense? So America
their factories were fine. Soviet Union
their factories were um uh removed into
Siberia far away from German from the
Germans. The Germans and the Japanese
could be firebombed. Okay. So look at
this. So uh from 1940 1945
the British and Americans firebombed
Germany. Okay, this is Dresston.
Dresdston, you can see the entire city
of Dresston was destroyed by the
firebombing. So in World War II, what
they what they recognized is there's no
point in killing soldiers on the
battlefield because they'll just send in
more soldiers with more weapons. So we
need to destroy the civilian population.
That's how you win the war. Okay. And
that's how and that's how they defeated
Germany. Japan was much worse. Look at
this. At least half of Japan was
destroyed by the American firebombing of
Japan. That's why Japan lost the war.
Otherwise, they would have kept on
going. All right? And these are huge
cities. So, Nagoya is a um city the size
of Los Angeles. 40% of it was destroyed.
Okay. Tokyo is New York City. 40% of it
was destroyed as well. Uh Yokohama, 60%
of it was destroyed. Okay, this is
Tokyo. You can see the extent of the
damage. The nation idea was so powerful
that in order to win a war, you you need
to destroy the the civilian population.
Okay.
So
um as you can see because because of the
rise of the nation state we have to kill
more and more people in order to fight
wars. So this is war two and
at least 20 to 30 more people were
killed.
Okay. And depending on your on how you
calculate probably a lot more than that
died. But what's interesting is that
even though World War II
was a calamity, even though tens of
millions have died, look at population
growth.
It didn't it never stopped. Okay?
So when so for most of history of human
history, population growth was steady.
But then starting around the year 1600,
it boomed. Okay? And again, scientists
will tell you this coincided with the
rise of science and technology. But
we've always had science and technology.
What made this different was the rise of
the nation state and the recognition
that to fight wars, you need more people
who wanted to kill themselves for the
nation.
And to get them to do that, you have to
treat them well as well. Okay? And
that's what and so the nation state
wanted science technology
to
grow the population. That's why we had
medicine and sanitation.
Okay. These innovations happen because
the nation state will these things to
happen.
All right.
Um, now as I mentioned,
after World War II
and after all the travesty and
destruction of World War II, the world
got together and said, "Okay, America,
you're you're in charge now and let's
build a world in which we don't have to
fight and kill each other anymore." And
so, America create this game, right,
called capitalism, consumer capitalism
in which we we live in today. And this
system is unique in human history. And
for most of this history was extremely
successful. It grew the population from
about 2 billion to about 8 billion
today. It made a lot of people more
wealthy. Think of the tremendous wealth
that China has generated in the past 30
40 years because of its participation in
consumer capitalism.
But unfortunately
um you we've now reached a point where
the system is offbalance. It's unst it's
unstable. It's unsustainable. So now
we're going back to war.
But unfortunately because there's so
many people this means that when when we
go back to war
at least 50% of humanity will die off in
World War II. Okay. So um this is the
war in Ukraine and already millions of
people are dying in this war. When you
look at the war in Ukraine, it's
essentially a 19th century
war. Okay? It's almost like World War I.
I know World War I happened in the 20th
century, but it's really a 19th century
war where you are trying to kill as many
soldiers as possible. Okay? And that's
what's happening in uh Ukraine.
Um the what I will show you is that Iran
will be the first 21st century
war. So
um America in round one
try to use shock and all.
Shock and all is basically you
decapitate the leadership.
Okay you destroy the military.
Okay. And you um destroy
production.
Right? That's the idea of shock and all.
I come in, I kill your leadership, I
kill your military, I kill your uh war
factories
and you do it as soon as possible. But
this is not working against Iran because
they prepared this. They prepared this
war for 20 years. So it's decentralized.
Okay?
So you've killed the leaders, but they
don't care because they have new leaders
coming into place. Um, the military is
hidden.
Okay, they're hidden in mountains and
the factories also hidden in mountains
as well. So even though the Americans
have really destroyed much of Iran's war
fighting capacity,
Iran is still in this fight. So what's
going to happen is that over the next
few months America is going to shift its
strategy into a 21st century war
strategy.
Okay, which will which will have three
components. Okay, the first component is
economic strangulation.
I will destroy your economy, your entire
economy. Second is ethnic tension.
I will try to create as much conflict as
possible between the different peoples
in
um Iran. Okay. And the third thing is
destroy
civilian infrastructure.
Basically, I want to destroy people's
capacity to access water, electricity,
and food. The basic necessities of life.
Why do I want to do that? Because if
people cannot access these things, they
get angry, right? Then if they get
angry, I can channel anger against the
government because it's easier for them
to attack the government than it's to
attack the US military, which which is
the ones destroying all this
infrastructure.
So this is what a 21st century
war strategy looks like.
And this is what the Americans will
deploy in Iran over the next few months.
Now, why haven't they done this before?
Well, because these are war crimes.
Okay? There are lots of treaties, the
Genev Geneva Convention that prohibit
you from fighting these wars. But
as the Americans become much more
desperate, as they continue to lose this
war, they'll be like, "Screw this. I'm
going to win this war no matter what it
takes. Okay. So, let me show you how how
this war will be fought. So, before
right now, they're trying to target
uh weapons. They're trying to target
military bases.
That doesn't get you anywhere. Okay? You
you need to better use your weapon
systems because there's you don't have
enough munitions to destroy the entire
Iranian military. Okay? So, so you have
to be strategic now. And so you target
things that have huge impact on the
civilian uh population as well as the
economy. Right? So the most most basic
thing is water. Okay? Look guys, these
are all dams and reservoirs
around Iran. Okay? I don't destroy all
of them, but I strategically destroy
some of them.
This is going to create a lot of
pressure on the on the civilian
population. They'll be very angry. They
might protest against the government.
Okay. Also,
um, transportation networks, right?
These are roads and railways. This is
important because Tran is a city of 10
million people and they do not grow
their own food. They they require food
to come from the countryside, from
elsewhere. So if I attack the roads
leading to Tran, if I attack strategic
hubs, then it's very hard for food to
move from place to place. Okay, I don't
have to destroy the entire food supply.
I can't do that. I don't have weapons,
but I'm being strategic about it. I'm
putting strain on Tran's capacity to
feed its own population power plants.
Okay, these are all power plants around
uh Iran and it's really easy to destroy
these power plants, right? So, does that
make sense? So, the idea is
war, the rules of engagement require me
to only attack soldiers and only attack
weapons,
but eventually I'm going to run out of
munitions if I keep on doing that. And
it's not going to destroy Iran's
capacity to fight. they won't surrender.
So now I need to be more strategic with
how I use my ammunitions, how I use my
bombs. And so I want to create as much
damage as possible. The best way to do
that is by targeting key infrastructure,
power plants, desalination plants,
roads, railway networks. Okay, I can't
destroy all of them, but I can create as
much havoc as possible over time. So the
civilian population gets very angry. So,
my best weapon in this war are no longer
my planes and my aircraft carriers. My
best weapon is the Iranian people
themselves. And that's what a 21st
century war looks like. It's very slow.
It's very methodical. It's pretty evil.
Okay.
All right.
All right. The other thing is economic
strangulation.
All right. So, what am I trying to do
here? Okay. So Iran there are two ways
for them to generate income for to
finance this war. The first is to sell
oil. Okay. And this is Car Island which
is their main depot. Okay. Oil depot.
And 90% of Iranian oil goes from Car
Island elsewhere. Okay. Primary to
China. 90% of Iran's oil exports goes to
China. Okay. So what Americans have done
is they've impos imposed a blockade
stopping
uh oil exports. Okay, that's one way you
can uh stop um Iran's economy. The other
thing is that right now Iran controls
the surf moose and they collect tolls on
that. Okay, so I basically need to
destroy Iran's control over the surf
moose. The way I do that is I use ground
forces. Okay. So, I what I can do is
seize Kam Island, seize Car Island,
seize the coastline, and force the
Iranians to respond to my attacks.
Right. I can also position
um forces here
and here. Why? Because these areas,
okay, in the northwest
of Iran are home to minorities as well
as the southeast.
And when I put my soldiers here, this is
going to encourage local population to
rise up against Iranian state. And now
what's going to happen is that the Iran
well Iran will now send forces to
respond to all these ethnic insurgencies
around
um Iran. Okay. So before Iran could just
focus its resources on controlling moves
like screw that I'm going to um expand
the battlefield so that Iran is forced
to deal with multiple threats at the
same time. I'm going to collapse their
economy.
All right. Okay. So, this is what a 21st
century war looks like. It's slow. You
you focus on triangulation as opposed to
a knockout punch.
All right.
So, um
once one way to understand what's
happening is that the Americans have
been doing this for a long time, but
more subtly. All right. So um in 2012
the Iranian president
named
Ahmad
Dijad he accused the Americans of
conducting
weather warfare against Iran mainly by
creating droughts in Iran. And how do
you do that? Well, it's cloud seating,
right? It's cloud seeding. So, the idea
of cloud seeding is that you shoot up a
chemical called silver
iodide into clouds, forcing it to rain.
Okay? When you do that, well, the clouds
dissipate the rain elsewhere and they
don't go to uh Iran. Okay? So, in 2019,
there's a real fear that Iran would
suffer from long-term drought
and regions like uh Dubai, which
Iranians claim to be the source of this
weather warfare, they experienced
droughts, sorry, sorry, floods. Okay.
All right. So again, I don't know how
the science works and this is all
rumors, but it does make sense where the
Americans would use weather warfare
against um Iran, forcing rain to come
down in Dubai to deny rain to the
Iranians. Okay.
Um there's a conspiracy theory that
these world governments are conducting
weather warfare using something called
HARP. Okay. Now, HARP was originally
designed in in order to study atosphere,
but some conspiracy theorists claim that
HARP can be used to create extreme
weathers, including hurricanes,
cyclones,
flooding, droughts. I don't know. Okay,
I I'm I'm just pointing this out there.
What we do know is that in 1962,
Lyndon Johnson, who became president of
United States, he had a very famous
quote at a speech and he basically said,
"He who controls the weather will
control the world." Okay? The future of
warfare is not about weapons. It's about
weather. So, it's not about how many how
many weapons you make, it's about how
well you can control the weather.
Because if you think about it, if you
can create a drought in a country, that
country will be destroyed.
Okay? And um they put a lot of resources
into developing uh weather warfare and
we know that from 1967 to 1972 the
Americans created call operation Popey.
Okay. Okay, so this is during the
Vietnam War and
um what the Americans did was they see
the clouds
so that the monsoon season would be a
lot longer in Vietnam. Why? Why do that?
Because then it's harder for the
Vietnamese
to resupply themselves. Okay, it makes
them hard it makes it harder for them to
fight because the Vietnamese are living
in tunnels, right? Whereas Americans are
attacking from the air. All right. So,
this is pretty well known. Operation
Popeye is something that the Americans
did do in Vietnam and they do have
weather manipulation technology. The
question is, debate is how effective the
technology is and how powerful is it and
how scalable is it. Okay.
Okay. That's the debate.
Um,
we're already seeing elements of 21st
century warfare being implemented around
the world. Okay. So, look at Cuba.
There's now a oil embargo on Cuba and so
they're blackouts.
All right. So again, the intention is
not to kill civilians. The intention is
not to fight a war. The intention is to
like strangle a nation so that
eventually the population wants to
overthrow the government. And already
what we're seeing is these past few
months lots of accidents around the
world that's destroying the world's oil
supply.
Okay. But there's only but there's one
region in the world that doesn't really
care about the loss of refineries, the
loss of oil oil supply, and that's North
America. Because North America is
extremely wealthy.
Um, and so when if the rest of the world
is facing energy scarcity and food
scarcity, it's it's going to have to beg
North America, United States, Canada,
Mexico for resources. And this allows
the Americans to better control the
world. Okay. Again, this is what 21st
century warfare looks like. All right.
The last another thing that I will point
out is that um the the Americans are
very good at overeing governments. Okay,
there's something called the color
revolution playbook. Color revolution
playbook.
And so what the Americans do is they
basically invite young people from
different nations to come to America to
learn about democracy to learn how how
to organize protest movements, how to
overthrow the government in order to
promote democracy. The Americans will
also finance nos in different countries
in order to create young movements in
the world. The Americans will also
control social media in order to
galvanize a population and ferment
unrest. Okay? And we saw this play out
most recently in 20 sorry last year
Nepal when young people overthrew the
government. Now guys, okay,
here's the thing. In Nepal, most people
don't speak English. They don't read
English. So, why are these young people
holding up signs? Okay, boomer, times
up. Okay, that's in English. Who's it
for? Also, okay, boomer is an American
phrase.
Okay, it's an American phrase, not a
Nepalese phrase. So, in other words,
they're doing this not to have impact
locally
in Nepal. They're doing this because
someone's paying them to do this. Do you
understand? It's being funded by
Washington and Washington's like, "Okay,
well, I'll pay you this much this amount
of money if you give me a slogan. If you
hold a slogan so I can show my boss
that this protest is working." Also,
guys, here's another sign. We pay you
flex enough. Okay. Another English sign.
So, again, why they doing this?
when the local local population don't
even speak English. They're doing it for
Washington. They're not doing it for
their own country. They're doing it for
their masters in Washington. All right.
Does that make sense? All right. And
this is very common in the world today
where these protests are being
orchestrated by Washington for
Washington as opposed to being organic.
Um this in 2010 2012 you have these Arab
Spring protests happen all around the
Middle East. Okay. Do they save lives in
the Middle East? And we know that social
media basically Twitter and Facebook
were instrumental
in organizing people and promoting
unrest in these places. All right. So
these are all called color revolutions
or the color revolution playbook.
So not only does America have the
capacity to strangle a nation's economy
and force the population to beg for
mercy,
Washington, the Americans also have
strategies on how to overthrow the
government using the local population.
Okay. Basically by uh controlling social
media, by organizing young people,
paying them to protest and bribing
security services to not intervene.
Okay. It's a very successful playbook.
They've tried many times and it's worked
many times before.
All right.
So,
America can use this playbook against
every country that opposes it. Okay. So
the main reason again is because America
controls the world's choke points
including uh Malaka, Panama Canal, uh
Jabalter. Uh these are the major uh
choke points. Even though um the
Iranians control the survival moves, the
Americans can have aircraft carriers in
the Indian Ocean and blockade the
Iranians. Okay, this is important
because a lot of people believe that
what America really wants to do is show
is just destroy China. And
unfortunately, right now a lot of the
Chinese economy depends on exports,
meaning trade. If you can't export, your
economy can suffer a great deal. when
your economy suffers a great deal, you
lose GDP, your unemployment and it's
possible that you have protest happening
in China uh because of
um the collapse of the economy. Okay, so
that is what a 21st century war looks
like. Okay, you don't send troops, you
don't destroy. What you do is you
strangle a people to death and force the
people to rise up against the um nation
nation state. Okay. And so the the
concluding message is this.
ultimately
to fight a 21st century warfare.
Okay,
it's really about population
management.
What I mean by that is
your enemy is trying to provoke your
population into unrest to destroy you.
So you have to respond by managing your
population better. Okay? And that can
often mean calling your population.
Calling your population just means um
killing them.
Okay? Killing them could mean you deny
them food. You you create famine.
Okay? You it could mean you spread
diseases.
It could mean you actually do go and
shoot them. Okay?
And this forces you to use artificial
intelligence, AI surveillance state,
because the best way to control your
population, the magic population, is
with an AI surveillance state. Right? So
that's the future. We're looking at what
a 21st century war looks like. And
there's no and there's no way around it.
It is just the in inability of history.
We have too many people. We want to
fight wars and so um a lot of people
have to die in these wars. Does that
make sense?
All right. Any questions, guys?
Any questions?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. C can you give
the microphone to
>> Yeah.
>> Uh I just have one small question about
the 20th century war. Like if a country
has been attacked by this strategy, how
can it respond? Like how can Iran it
responds to American strategy right now?
Okay, back to your question.
Okay.
Look, the reality is that when the
Americans do this,
okay, when when they do three things,
right? They um uh destroy your economy,
when they strangle, sorry, when they
destroy your infrastructure,
and when they divide and conquer.
According to game theory, there's only
one response.
Okay? There's only one proper response
to to this and this idea of esquetology.
Okay? And the idea here is this,
you need to create fanaticism
among your people,
right? Because your people are
suffering.
They don't have enough. They don't have
enough to eat.
They don't have any hope in the future.
So what you say to them is this all part
of God's plan. We're meant to suffer
because when we suffer, God will make us
invincible. For our suffering, we'll
find the courage to commit martyrdom.
Okay? When we do martyrdom, we go to
heaven.
All right. The problem with this is that
most people don't want to do this. Okay?
They're like, "No, I don't want to kill
myself. I don't want to die for God. I
just want to live a normal life."
Okay? But unfortunately, what history
tells us is that you really don't need
that many people to commit to
esquetology to win a war. maybe at most
um 10 to 20 percent. If you if 10 to 20%
of your population commit to this
esquetology then um you will survive.
Okay, we have an example of this. We
have an example of this is the uh U
sorry the Iran Iraq war which is what
happened in the 1980s. Okay, an 8-year
war between Iran and Iraq. All right.
And guys, it was a crazy war. These
Iraqis were supported by both the
Americans and the Soviet Union.
They had tanks. They had helicopters.
They had a professional army. The
Iranians in 1980s didn't have an army.
They didn't have tanks. They didn't have
they didn't have um helicopters. So what
they said to people is
the greatest glory is to be a martyr.
The greatest glory is to die for your
nation and for God. So they all these
young people went into the battle with
just a rifle. Okay guy like like imagine
this. Okay, you have this young guy 16
years old. He's running into battle
against a tank in a helicopter and he's
screaming at them. I will kill you.
And most of them got blown up, but some
of them got through and they threw a
grenade into the tank.
Okay, now you think you you you you
think about this, you're like, "Oh my
god, that's crazy." But first of all, it
galvanized Iranian population into
resisting and event and eventually they
turned the tide of the war so that they
were actually winning the war. And it
was only because the Americans start to
use chemical weapons against them that
the Iranians had to were forced back.
Okay? But if if left alone, the Iranians
would have to feed the Iraqis.
So think about that. How it gized the
population into resistance. The other
thing is that it scared the hell out of
the Iraqis. Okay, you are you have a
tank, right? The guy's coming at you
with a rifle and a grenade. He's not
afraid of you. His fear his fearlessness
makes you afraid.
Okay.
So even though yes in 21st century
warfare okay it seems invincible but
esquetology
is the counter to
this approach. And that's why we should
see over the next few years a huge surge
in esquetology and religious f extremism
throughout the world because it's really
the only counter to um this type of
warfare. Does does that make sense?
Okay, great question. Any more
questions, guys? Okay, great. So,
there's no class on Thursday and next
Tuesday, but we'll come back next
Thursday and we'll continue this. Okay.
All right. Thank you.